on the heels of calling roughly half the
country semi-fascist the biden
administration is now somehow
upping the rhetoric referring to us all
as a quote
extreme threat to democracy
the president thinks that there is an
extremist threat to our democracy
the president has been clear as he can
be on that particular
piece when we talk about a democracy
when we talk about our freedoms
the way that he sees is the mag of
republicans are the most energized part
of the republican party
the that extreme this is an extreme
threat to our democracy to our freedom
uh to our rights
notice that line was not off the cuff
that was not merely some gaff from
corrine jean-pierre or joe biden she was
reading off of her written notes she
repeated the phrase
the white house made a conscious
decision to refer to magga republicans
the same way that they would refer to
isis actually probably more harshly than
they would refer to isis the lib is
called the leader of isis an austere
religious scholar the libs hand
afghanistan over to the taliban okay
they're actually pretty nice to the
terrorists and to isis and al qaeda and
all those people
they reserve the terrorist rhetoric
for you
for parents and for conservatives and
for mega republicans with which by the
way just means republicans
that's it that's all there is the never
trump movement at this point is pretty
much just bill crystal and five or six
people that he has over to complain
about donald trump over t okay
statistically for all intents and
purposes maga republicans
just means republicans
which means the president of the united
states
the same president who keeps threatening
to strafe us all with squadrons of f-15s
is saying that half of the country
should be treated as terrorists he's
saying that the only way we can have
government of the people by the people
and for the people is if we get rid of
half the people
a bad idea in general
an especially bad idea when those half
of the people
are you
we need to add another coin to the
donald trump was right jar
this i always try to to
keep the receipts here you know because
here's what happens in politics
a conservative says something
the liberals say that's crazy that's
stupid you're an idiot you don't know
anything that's wrong that's dangerous
it's a horrible idea and then
i don't know call it six months later
sometimes even a couple of years later
the conservative has proven completely
correct and we say hey we were right the
whole time and then what did the lib say
no never mind what are you talking about
who remembers that now forget about it
move along move along and rinse and
repeat that goes on and on and on then
the conservatives will observe something
they'll say wait hold on no this is what
i think the let's say no you're
completely wrong it's stupid they'll
laugh at us they'll ridicule us well
this is what's happening right now
when it comes to energy
you might recall
a few years ago donald trump
warned that europe's energy policy right
now was making europe and germany in
particular extremely reliant on russia
to heat the homes and power the cars and
keep germany going and at the time all
the libs and germany in particular
mocked donald trump for this observation
this was considered so risible that the
the the american left-wing news outlets
put out joke compilations of trump
making this claim this is a clip from
now this which is a
left-wing
news source and commentary source
mocking is from the time mocking trump's
suggestion
germany's reaction to trump's inaccurate
claim is priceless become totally
dependent
on russian energy
if it does not immediately change
course no they're laughing
look at that look at those germans
they're laughing ah or is that idiot
trump trump's claim is not accurate and
highly misleading cnbc says germany
imports only a fraction of its total
energy from russia
we are committed
to maintaining our independence
from the encroachment
of expansionist foreign powers
now this
there it is
okay so how's that shaping up well
russia just announced that it's gonna
cut off germany's gas supply
via the nordstrom one pipeline for three
days just three days okay well that
shouldn't matter at all right nothing's
going happen because trump's a big dumb
stupid idiot right and he said that
germany is too reliant on russian energy
and all the germans left okay
okay so who cares they're gonna shut off
this one pipeline for three days no big
deal right well here's what the german
economy minister robert habeck told the
financial times
apparently this this move by russia to
shut off the gas for just three days has
already forced german companies to stop
production
it's a development that he said is
alarming he said quote it's not good
news because it can mean that the
industries in question aren't just being
restructured but are experiencing a
rupture a structural rupture one that is
happening under enormous pressure
oh
not laughing now i guess
the germans have said what can we do
with the three-day pause they said i
assume that we will be able to cope with
it that was klaus mueller the president
of germany's network regulator that's we
told reuters i trust that russia will
return to 20 on saturday but no one can
really say oh so it sounds like trump
was
100 correct
and all the germans were laughing and
all the news outlets called trump a big
stupid dumb idiot and all the
conservatives who followed trump were
just stupid idiot rubes who don't know
anything about energy except
we were all completely right
and all of the geniuses at msnbc and the
financial analysts and the establishment
and the things they were all completely
wrong
that's what happened and it's very
important to point this out because it
keeps happening that's why i keep
focusing on this when it comes to covid
we were right about the masks all of the
genius
authorities and experts and fauci and
all the big tech censors and all of the
all of the petty government officials
from the local level to the
international level
they were they were wrong we were right
about the masks all of them were wrong
about the masks except for fouchy
briefly when he was being honest about
the masks but then he reversed his
position how about the vaccines when we
said i don't think the vaccines are
actually going to stop you from catching
covet or spreading it and then
everyone all the experts all the
authorities said the opposite and they
all called us a bunch of big dumb stupid
idiots and science deniers and all the
rest we were 100 right they were 100
percent wrong
same thing catching cover transmitting
covet the the risks of the vaccines
initially we were told there no risks to
the vaccines we said i think there
actually are probably some some pretty
serious risks we were 100 right they
were 100 wrong and it's not it wasn't
just covid that this is the fa the case
on it's it's everything
it's everything from the covid masks to
the russian and german energy sectors
our experts are established geniuses who
have the power to
form public opinion and exclude certain
opinions
they don't know anything okay and joe
schmo on the street and joe schmoe's
representative named donald trump
are much much more correct they have a
much much better record than these
people do i'm glad you like that clip
now
ring that bell subscribe we've hit a
million subscribers that's great i want
to hit a billion so head on over right
now ring that bell get the notifications
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]